sign 975 man Ready Set Radio live in
studio right now one of my favorite
rappers this dude is killing the game
Kendrick Lamar in the building sir what
up with a boy man i'm chillin it's nice
to finally meet you man I'm a big fan
this is your year so far homie I'm
trauma section 80 yeah that's about
right now right what is a of course the
response has been crazy man like like
how do you feel about the feedback from
from the project so far and I love him
and everybody's been real receptive the
accomplishment no was to go in with a
project that spoke about my generation
yeah I mean people I grew up with and
people around the world man that's my
age and I said section 80 everything
from the 1980s all the way to 2011 right
right right what I represent us when I
speak for and I feel like I accomplished
because I go any streets never let man
yeah you did it for and I it was just
kind of like the way you have asked its
laid out throughout the album yes it was
perfect you know yeah man um you you
release it on iTunes and I remember I
think I think Dave tweeted like I think
it was top five or something on the rap
charts yeah what was the heist I got a
peek the one hey you got it got it to
number one that's see that's crazy yes I
see I knew that's what I appreciate
about what you guys are doing you guys
are kind of making it okay to like you
know it's okay to sell your music right
you know a lot of people you know talk
about how black music is out and they
tired of hearing this and that right
well the percentage that's good let's go
out and support it yes yes I will go get
it back to the floor because the last
like two or three years it's like
everyone's putting out everything for
free and yes you know I think people are
starting to get spoiled and you know
it's good that you know you came out hit
number one on iTunes yeah yeah same
thing like absolutely the same thing
with his project what you did the same
thing with his project um what's next
for you as a solo artist what's the next
part on instant debut damn you know I
want to show they out the official debut
dumb when I wanted to section 80 I
wanted that to be a solidifies a warm up
for what I really but as a hell of a
warm outside yeah so once everybody once
the debut come out here I can get the
whole collection in
really no do you have kendrick lamar's
everyone's being hella secretive with it
with album titles as of late are you one
of those guys I'm up in the air right
now um I got an idea you got idea what I
want to call it but I want to get the
music first right how how far you are
into recorder have you started I have so
much material man i just can't I got
something yeah yeah yeah I have probably
like seventy percent seventy percent I
can't really give a percentage because i
have so much music and I just constantly
record and come over yeah you never know
what's gonna make it right he said who
do you what what as far as features on
the new album on I mean it's your debut
album yeah um you know some people with
the debut album you know they have a lot
of features now I only had one finisher
on hill matic what is your stance on
that who do you do you want to get on
the album are you gonna go dolo on it I
really want to go dole on it because I
really want to get the four-story yeah
you know it make it make sense any if I
do do a feature have to make a hundred
percent best sense yeah yeah I know I
don't really want to force nothing well
all my music you know I don't like
before even even though features i do
with in my camp right then features have
to make sense with me i can't just do it
just because it's cuz I Schoolboy Q you
two homie injera like you too homie AB
you know me alright have to be organic
gotta be that's how I started music is
made so um you are doing okay on the
independent level yeah you uh you don't
definitely don't need a major label your
you know probably the hottest hottest
one of the top three hottest cats in the
game right now right um I know if you
want I mean I know you're not signed are
you rolling with cheetah hmm it's a
major label um is that something you're
going to look into I mean it's um
definitely something we looking into now
just because we know that we made the
groundwork yeah and and a post of 10 I
mean seven years ago would have been
somebody knocking on independent label
knocking on a major label door and then
being signed and getting a whole thing
reconstructed the way they want to do it
so whenever signs like whoever decides
is like get a TD for like distribution
right ever there they're coming up right
so that is option i know it's aftermath
on the table it's an option it is an
option um probably got it I probably
everybody's an option right right yeah I
just pick and choose man
it's a blessing you know because at one
point we was knocking on label the
doorman right now the knot on your nuts
with the kid and it just feels organic
you know and the best the best way it
can come out is the only knowing and
understanding the ground work that we've
done and just want to be a part of it
and make it that much more bigger not
going into a situation where the whole
viral and the plan gets switched up
because we see y'all as an entity and
what y'all done right there own entity
first it's kind of like it's kind of you
know the same thing I have more ways
like not Wiz came up exact he had his
run with the labels but a kind of laid
the groundwork yeah but he came to him
so I had a question that I had to ask
because on overly dedicated hoc the song
yeah all right and then on section 80
there's like a weed pipe on the cover
yeah yeah and then there's the cushion
Corinthian song so in between those two
projects yeah you picked up on the only
on the cushion oh no see the thing is I
love you way I'm glad that you actually
okay yeah cuz I like that's what
question I'm like house I made I don't
smoke we personally I was like all right
cool finally a rapper they don't smoke
right way I mean overly dedicated was
more about me section 80 is written
about your people yeah everybody so when
I say cushion Corinthians this is a
story I mean I put jabs in two by myself
but the song is basically based around
no one of my homeboys okay well his
homeboy okay that's so yeah cuz cuz me
and Mike me and my boy we're like when
uh yeah sexually first came out that's
the first thing we noticed something
else when the artwork came out were like
wait a minute yeah that's how kendrick
in smoke yeah there's a pipe on the
cover what the hell yeah that's that's
our generation yummy definitely smoking
as it it's not even a I won't even say a
cool thing to do the boys just a fad now
is there anything you do so it is why
I'm making light of the reference in
section 8 yeah that's what's up um as
far as a j Cole is concerned I know you
guys have a close he produced high power
yes sir murder that beat appreciate it
um there's been talk that you guys gonna
drop something together yet has that
already been recorded is it in the can
we have a lot of material but the thing
is we got to work around each other
schedules right now
ligue 1 record just one right right this
gives one everybody's waiting man is it
is really anticipated for real we just
really want to sit and like any
structure everything on a organic level
instead going through conflicts of
schedule yeah I interviewed him like I
in December and that is the one I
remember was talking I was like yo who
you checking for rhinos like Kendrick
this is before yo man cuz I remember
like two weeks later the video kicked
like when you guys met and all that came
out right he was like Kendrick Lamar son
he's like she needs to be front and
center on the double XL cover no one is
[__] with ya that's my doing okay
let's ride for you for real and uh uh
you know where I appreciate about yours
your style your music like you said it's
organic like it you you had like you
don't sound like anybody to me like I
think your flow is original your you
make good hip-hop music man and yeah and
that's something that is starting to
slowly I think come back a little bit
and I just something that took really a
lot of years is preparation and it's
funny you say that because what the
beginning of we actually doing music I
sounded like everybody else oh word yeah
man I studied pot yeah I met you know as
funny as I met you a long ass time ago
in Phoenix Arizona at a studio in mesa
arizona j-rock was yep I was right
what's it called what's his name mr.
salt mine it's not mine yeah I was it
was a brief me buddy knows how you were
back then yeah I was in the cut man
you're soaking up the game yeah yeah
yeah yeah um as far as I saw something
online that you had like some sort of
like like like two pocket visited you
want to dreamers engine um and that that
was kind of that inspired you to do
high-power am I getting that right yeah
well not that record it inspired me to
do the type of music that I'm going down
just in general you know as far as music
that touch people and music that moves
people right right right on whether
you're happy whether you said whether
you depressed or something that you can
relate to and um that's a real visual
man if I got man that's ways yeah yeah
yeah how long ago did it happen I want
to say at least a lot ha ha powering up
there's 15 head around that time that's
crazy because I went in the studio
probably like the next few days and
rocked out on a reg I already had to
premeditated but it really gave me extra
go to are you were you on a big to part
I mean you're from cali of course were
you big on Tupac coming up of course you
know but the thing was about it I mean
we always young cash burn up in healing
so we didn't really know how big of
artists this person was because we
couldn't really interpret it being eight
nine years old I see our older cousin
how are you I'm from 24 oh you so we're
the same age right so like I kind of
came up like like yeah like I was like
you know I don't I was like seven with
you guys yeah yeah you know I'm saying
aight not yeah yeah and yeah like I mean
like I was like we came up on like dmx
JS yes sir don't win the record yes sir
cashman cash money and fifty even a
little bit you know what I'm saying so
yeah that's that's why I like that's
because you have a lot of I would say
that you're you're like it like you make
real hip-hop music what were some of
your like main influences I mean besides
park and besides pie well I started
rhyming of dmx first album man classic
is marcus is that that's that album does
not get talk to them talked about enough
I never forget I was in seventh grade my
homie Antonio just do the CD in my aunt
there is the movie babe and put on I put
that in man and I was a blast in it yeah
and I start pinning my own music so
DMX's exe a deal mix yeah DMX men DMX
and Kendrick on a record would be crazy
oh man though that would be nuts dope
bad Lex got make next time you're out
there he'll only got heart homie right
hopefully he's in the right he's all
good he won't be back in jail by then
hopefully yeah he should be straight man
you should be straight Oh Willa I detox
man yes sir I know you're a part of the
creative process with the album I know
you've been in there and so do I mean
what is what is your inside all day is
it going to come out because I know it
was supposed to come out right in April
and then I don't I didn't I never
thought I was a perfectionist I thought
I was that the the big you thought you
were saying no to yeah raisin perfection
tres tres the Keen profess the king he
crashed a lambo in the music
that'd be like okay let's put this
[__] album out yeah yeah he asked the
King here man and when it's all said and
done people what is on the answer for
your role you have you done any writing
for a ghost riding it or you just
featured on the album a little bit
everything man just I mean he lets me go
in the studio and just let me vibe out
and that's what I love the most about is
really no restraints you know because he
believed in my sound and my music that
much more so that's what's up me your
boy jay rock just dropped his album yes
sir I'm all strange music yes sir um who
gonna love me yes a great great record
you just did the game record yeah um I
know you know game was kind of like the
face of the west coast for a long time I
mean I'd say he's I mean you know games
kind of kind of not been as big as he
was but he still kind of is the main
dude you know that um how did that
record come about he basically just
reached out you know well I take it back
we've been riding with gang I've been
rifling games another five like 18 right
my do top dog made the connection that's
dope yeah that's right cuz I I was in
the watch the throne right and I was
very disappointed and then I listened
and I'm a gun I myself with me to Kanye
Stan like every time I [__] love
Kanye I'm man but I was very
disappointed okay right album I heard
was the first song with you and I was
like man this is already better than
watch the throne don't man that's dope I
haven't heard it I haven't heard the
whole album yet not a noise anymore drop
it's certainly dope um what do you have
you at what's your thoughts on washes oh
that's the biggest thing going on right
now in the game watch the throne I like
it I like in front of someone has to
grow on your thing yeah I roll with it
for a while and I plan a nice to really
start the first time I listened to it I
was like he's time I sweat I mean
there's there's some records on there
there i mean i like it just because of
the fact I I understand i can get it I
mean I can't relate to it I can't relate
but I I understand you know what they
was doing in yeah yeah there's just
starting out for all you know watch the
throne I mean it's two kings right here
watchin Dan throw that [__] cray right
now about topping to the first song yes
sir on section 8 E is my joint man what
you tell us about this song is after
your ethnicity ethnicity um I got
inspired off this on well to write the
song because a particular show that I
had
they looked in the crowd and I seen all
these different type of beautiful people
man in yeah man and it's crazy how music
can bring people together like that no I
once dreamed that well thought about
we're doing a show a big venue in it
should be all you know minority but now
I yeah right okay yeah after your
density there it is get it Sinai 75
Ready Set Radio yes sir